- [Instructor] In a video game,
Val scored 30% fewer points than Peeta.
Peeta scored 1,060 points.
How many points did Val score?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure out
how many points Val scored.
Alright, now let's do this together.
And there's a couple of ways
that you could think about it.
One way to think about is
Peeta scored 1,060 points,
and Val scored 30% fewer.
When we're saying 30% fewer,
we're saying essentially take 30% of 1060
and subtract that from 1060.
So 30%, so we could write
that as a decimal as 0.30.
30/100 is the same thing as 30%,
or we could even write this as .3.
And then we would want 30% of 1060.
So if you take Peeta's score
and then subtract 30% of Peeta's score,
then this would give you Val's score.
So that's one way to calculate it.
Another way to think about is
whatever you're starting
with, let's call that 100%,
and if you were to take out 30% of it,
if you were to have 30% less,
then you're going to have
70% of what you started with.
So another way to think about it is
we could take Peeta's score of
1060 and multiply it by 70%.
And multiplying it by
70% is the same thing
as multiplying it by 0.70,
which is the same thing as
multiplying it by 70/100,
is the same thing as 7/10.
So let's just do this.
So if I have 1060, and I multiply by 0.7,
what do I get?
Seven times zero is zero.
Seven times six is 42.
Seven times zero is
zero, plus four is four.
Seven times one is seven.
And I have one digit to
the right of the decimal.
So there you have it, it is 742.
742.
That is how many points Val scored.
Let's do another example.
So we're told there are 20% more goblins
than wizards in a magic club.
There are 220 goblins and
wizards altogether in magic club.
How many goblins are in the magic club?
So pause the video and see
if you can work through this on your own.
So this one is an interesting one.
It's gonna involve a
little bit of algebra here.
So what we wanna do is
let's set a variable.
Let's say w is the number of wizards.
So that's the number of wizards.
And then if we said g for
goblins, let's say g for goblins.
So w plus g is equal to 220,
is equal to 220.
And you're like, well,
how does that help me?
How does that help me actually figure out
how many goblins are in the magic club?
I have two variables
here with one equation.
Well, one way to think about it is,
remember, they give us
some more information.
They tell us there are
20%, let me box that,
there are 20% more goblins than wizards.
So we also know one other thing.
We know that the goblins,
we know that the goblins
are equal to the number
of wizards plus 20%.
So you could view this as wizards
plus 20% of wizards.
And I'm writing that as 20/100,
or you could even write that as 2/10,
plus 2/10 times the number of wizards.
Or another way of thinking about it,
goblins are equal to, if
I have one of something
and then I have another
2/10 of that something,
then I'm gonna have 1.2 of that something.
So goblins is equal to
1.2 times the wizards.
And so we could use that
to substitute back in here,
and then we could say
the number of wizards
plus the number of goblins,
which happens to be 20% more
than the number of wizards,
is going to be equal to 220.
Let me do that in that same color.
Is equal to 220.
Now this is pretty
straightforward to solve.
What is w plus 1.2w?
Well, that is going to be 2.2w, 2.2w.
You could view this as one w plus 1.2w
is 2.2w is equal to 220.
And so just divide both sides.
Let me scroll down a little bit.
Divide both sides by 2.2, 2.2,
and what do you get?
You get w, the number
of wizards is equal to,
let's see, this is going
to be equal to 100.
The number of wizards is equal to 100.
Now is that our answer?
No, they're asking how many
goblins are in the magic club?
Well, we know that goblins
are 1.2 times the wizards.
So the number of goblins is
going to be 1.2 times 100,
which is equal to 120.
So there's 120 goblins,
does that make sense?
120 is 20% more than 100.
And if you add the 100
wizards to the 120 goblins,
you get 220 goblins
and wizards altogether.
Let's do another example.
Here we're told Cody
was 165 centimeters tall
on the first day of school this year,
which was 10% taller than he was
on the first day of school last year.
How tall was Cody on the
first day of school last year?
Pause this video, see if
you can figure that out.
So let's just define a variable here.
Let's just say that his
height on the first day
of school last year,
let's say that that is x.
So his height on the first
day of school last year is x.
This year he is 10% taller,
so we would add 10%, which
we could say is 10/100,
or we could even say that as 1/10.
He's 1/10 taller.
So whatever his height was last year,
we're going to add 1/10
of that same height again
to get to his height this year,
which they tell us is 165 centimeters.
And so here we could say
well, one x plus 1/10 of an x
is going to be one and
1/10x is equal to 165.
And now to solve for x, which
remember, was his height
on the first day of school last year,
we divide both sides by 1.1.
And so x is equal to,
well, let's see what this is going to be.
If I were to take 165 divided by 1.1,
the first thing I would wanna do
is multiply them both by 10.
So that has the effect of moving
this decimal place one to the right.
So really, I am now trying to figure out
what 11 goes into 1,650 is.
And so let's see, let me
just do that step by step.
11 goes into 16 one time.
One times 11 is 11.
Subtract, we get a five,
and we bring down a five.
11 goes into 55 exactly five times.
Five times 11 is 55.
Subtract.
We have no remainder, but
then we bring down this zero
and we do it one more time.
11 goes into zero zero times.
Remember, the decimal
place is right over here.
Zero times 11 is zero, and
then we have no remainder.
So last year he was 150 centimeters.
And it's always good
to do a reality check.
Make sure, if for example,
if I divided wrong
and I somehow got 15, or I got 1500,
just to make sure that that
wouldn't make any sense.
150 centimeters, you add 10% of that.
10% of 150 is 15 centimeters.
So you add 10% of that, you indeed do get
to 165 centimeters for the
first day of school this year.